[Applause]
is
a happy ending and this is my theory on
it
i don't think a happy ending from an
uglier
girl is cheating not
if you ask a woman it is because you're
happy and that's the keys
if she directly calls the happiness
you're cheating on her yeah that's the
point uh
okay so no happiness involved
yeah just guilty my girl is fun that's
wild that's that'd be disrespectful
but is the act of a happy ending
cheating
apparently it is i didn't think so at
first
how'd you find out
we are planning our my friend's bachelor
party
and i went to his fiancee and asked
how much are we allowed to do at the
bachelor party
are robin tuggs okay
and then she yelled at me and then my
friend
uninvited me to the bachelor party is
that right
funny how people get uninvited
you [ __ ] benedict arnold
hey but yeah i really didn't think
rubber tugs were cheating because here's
my thing looked at it like oh no you're
just it's a massage
let me throw something out there let me
throw something out there right massage
not cheating
fine touching genitals appears to be
cheating
yeah okay if i touch my own genitals
not cheating correct if the girl
is as ugly as me
what's the difference it's not you
and no doctor can tuck my touch my
genitals yeah but it's not sexual in
nature
you're not says who i hope you what if i
have a female doctor and she's hot but i
don't let her know it
what if i have a female doctor who has
to rub my balls and i just happen to
come
i'm gonna be honest no i think your girl
will call that cheating how is that
cheating the doctor is checking for
cancer
and i'm just like keep checking right
and she's rubbing your balls and you nut
off a ball rub
and i nut off a ball rip don't judge my
don't judge
my nut it doesn't touch the dick no dick
touch i nut off a ball rub
if you put it like that she still thinks
you're cheating
how is that cheating when we're trying
to inject logic into women it ain't
gonna happen
okay but what we're gonna have to do in
order to have this discussion is to have
some sort of base and logic
okay okay just a small semblance of
logic
automatically it's not realistic if i'm
not
off of a medical
procedure it's not cheating
that seems valid you can't control it
you can't control it right
so let's say i'm getting physical
therapy
and my thighs are getting rubbed because
i pulled my thighs
that'll make your dick move maybe and
i'm not off of that is that cheating you
know what it might be the intention
if the intention is to come then you're
cheating
what if i'm just like i don't want to
come i would like you to massage my dick
oh i don't want to come robin tugging
don't come
is it cheating is is your intention for
real
i don't want to come no let's go back
let's go back this is actually really
good here
rub and tug no [ __ ] cheating again i
think if your intention
is to not nut i think you're fine
i could try to not not that's easy
i try not not every single time no but
your intention is
look i don't want to come i just want
you know i just want a massage my dick
is mad stressed you know i mean
yep it's got some knots in it just work
out the nuts i don't want to come
okay if you sense i'm about to come just
stop okay
that's not cheating maybe not i don't
think so i think that they would think
anything
that is touching of genitals is cheating
oh caveat
what if it's a male doctor now we're
talking is that cheating
no is it gay yes yes
is it gay if you get a ball rub from a
male doctor and you nut
on his face i don't see how it's not
okay to be honest with you
i didn't even think that was a question
that needed to be asked
no let's think about this let's think
about this
if you have a ball or dick
rub yeah not coming
it's still cheating because girls do not
want another girl to touch your dick
yeah we're on the same page with that
right
if you have a leg rub that you end up
coming from
cheating
i don't know that's a good question she
was damn right
you don't think that your girl's going
to be upset if you bust a nut no she
would think it is but how no
exact exact exactly there's no logic
here
i'm just trying to present a situation
where we could convince our girls that
we should be able to get our dicks
jerked off yeah so i think they should
stop opening up massage parlors start
opening physical therapy
clinics clinics and then we all pull our
groins at around the same time
that's what i'm [ __ ] talking about
it's a wellness center absolutely
think about it it's our spa day